تشهد شبكه القطارات في اكبر ثلاثه اقاليم
في المملكه المتحده شلالا كبيرا في اول
يوم عمل في العام الجديد ويعود اكثر من
40,000 من العاملين في شركات تشغيل
القطارات الى الاضراب اليوم وغدا مما ادى
الى الغاء اربعين اربع من كل خمسه رحلات
على شبكه القطارات وتشهد بريطانيا ايضا
عوده للاضرابات من قبل المشرفين على
اختبارات قياده السيارات والعاملين في
اداره الطرق السريعه في مناطق عده
ويطالبوا المغربون بتحسين اجورهم وظروف في
عملهم بشكل يتناسب
معدلاته التضخم
معنى من داخل محطه لندن بريج مراسله جزيره
اسد الله الصاوي اسد الله يعني شلل كبير
في اول ايام عمل العام الجديد كيف تتعامل
معه السلطات ومع مطالب المغربي
[موسيقى]
في فريق الجزيره للدخلها الى هذه المحطه
احد اكبر المحطات القطارات في وسط لندن
محطه ولكن قيل لنا ان اخر قطار من هذه
المحطه وصل قبل نحو ربع ساعه من الان وان
المحطه باتت مغلقه هذه المحطه عاده تعمل
حتى ساعات الصباح الاولى ونحن الان في
اواخر ساعات همم 80% من رحلات القطارات في
انجلترا واسكتلندا وويلز تم الغاءها اليوم
20% الباقيه همم
سارت بتاخير كبير وبتراض كبير في حركه همم
الشبكه همم هذا الاضراب اثر كثيرا على همم
بدايه العام الجديد نحن اول ايام العمل في
العام الجديد كما قلتي وهذا الاضراب يتوقع
ان يستمر لمده خمسه ايام هناك تلميحات من
مصادر تابعه للحكومه بان همم هناك اتفاقا
او بان هناك اتفاق وشيكا يمكن ان يتم
ابرائه بين نقابات عمال السكك الحديديه
والحكومه لكن النقابات نفذ هذه المعلومات
تاثير الاضرابات كبير سيامه همم ايضا في
الطرق السريعه التي تعتبر ربما بديلا
بخارج المدن عن حركه القطارات العمال في
اداره شبكات الطرق السريعه في المناطق
عديده من انجلترا همم مضربون هم ايضا
ولدينا اضراب ممتحنين قياده السيارات وهذا
ايضا اضراب مستمر منذ فتره وغدا يبدا
اضراب عدد كبير من سائقه حافلات النقل
العام في مناطق بوسط وغرب لندن حتى الان
السلطات تتحدث ربما عن امكانيه وجود همم
يعني فور سالي اتفاق ولكن ليس هناك بارقه
امل محدده
من داخل محطه لندنش